what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and a lot has been happening in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe lately not
just in the universe itself but with
Marvel Studios as well yesterday we
talked about the changes that Marvel
Studios could be implementing with the
MCU relatively soon a strategy of
cutting back severely on Disney Plus
shows now in the video yesterday I asked
you all what you thought about it and I
saw a lot of comments talking about how
yes there have been a lot of shows
coming from Marvel Studios lately the
frequency is high for the Disney Plus
shows but first and foremost the quality
just has been a little bit lacking that
is just one of the issues that Marvel
Studios right now is trying to fix and
it looks like they're going to be doing
this in another big way as well
something that we haven't entirely
gotten yet is a ton of connectivity in
the MCU with so many different projects
and movies going on sometimes it's
really hard to tell how everything is
connecting but apparently that is going
to be changing really soon into two
specific projects now of course they'll
show us the connectivity in other
projects as well but we're hearing that
one specific project is going to fill in
the gaps of a lot of other shows and
movies that we've seen that we've been
waiting for we've been waiting for these
gaps to be filled we've been waiting to
feel a more connectivity to the MCU and
everything has been set up even in these
individual Disney Plus shows the ones
that feel like they haven't connected
they will indeed start to feel like that
soon and with the other movie it's not
necessarily going to fill in the gaps
like this other movie is but bring
everything together making everything
feel really connected and pushing that
connectivity forward in the MCU so we'll
break down everything you need to know
in this video including talking about
the one project that Marvel Studios is
going to use to connect a lot of the MCU
together so if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss any of the
latest MCU news and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items as well
the winner gets to pick one item and we
pick a winner at the end of each month
among the complaints of Marvel fans
recently has been that they feel a lack
of connectivity but in the start of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in Phase 1 and
phase two there wasn't a ton of
connectivity yet yes everything did
connect and there were Easter eggs and
tie-ins to other projects but until
really phase three started there wasn't
a ton of connectivity just think back on
the first two phases we had Iron Man The
Incredible Hulk Iron Man 2 Thor Captain
America and the Avengers film all of
those really stood on their own of
course they connected and had Easter
eggs and tie-ins to other movies but for
the most part they were their own films
but then in phase two we got Iron Man 3.
that was really on its own except for
Tony talking about the Battle of New
York and how he had PTSD from it Thor
the Dark World really stood on its own
then we had Captain America the Winter
Soldier that movie felt connected
because Nick Fury was in it black Widow
was in it Bucky was in it as the Winter
Soldier of course but Guardians of the
Galaxy stood on its own and that is
really kind of when we met Thanos for
the first time and that's kind of where
it starts Ant-Man kind of stood on its
own we did have the scene where he goes
to the Avengers facility and fights
Falcon but again for the most part that
film was on its own it was only until
phase three where everything felt super
connected because we had Captain America
civil war that brought all the previous
Heroes together Dr Strange and Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 2 really stood on
their own as well but they were brought
in in a really big way in Avengers
Infinity War then Spider-Man homecoming
of course felt super connected because
it had Tony Stark Thor Ragnarok had the
Hulk and it picked up right after Civil
War black panther was a movie on its own
but of course it connected to Infinity
war in a really big way as well and then
with Ant-Man and the WASP the ending
directly tied into Infinity war and
would end up going right into Avengers
end game minus Captain Marvel which
doesn't take place at the same time in
the MCU of course but Captain Marvel was
brought in and in game and then after in
game we had Spider-Man far from home
which of course still really showed the
presence of Tony Stark but again all
these really big projects that felt
super connected didn't really happen
until phase three and that's kind of
where we're heading right now we haven't
seen too much connectivity but the first
two phases didn't show a lot of it as
well originally what brought the heroes
and projects together were the Avengers
films and we're about to kind of get our
first mini Avengers film with Captain
America Brave New World this is one of
the films that I was talking about this
is supposed to be kind of just like
Captain America Civil War now when I say
that I don't mean the Avengers are going
to be fighting each other but I mean
it's basically going to be a big
Ensemble of superheroes coming together
on screen an unofficial Avengers film
because that's what everybody kind of
considers Captain America Civil War and
Avengers film without the title and
again like I mentioned Civil War was a
huge project for the MCU as a whole
because moving forward from there a lot
of things really started to connect more
and it looks like that's the same thing
that is going to be happening right
after Captain America Brave New World
our heroes are going to come together
and they're going to stay together for
the future going into the King Dynasty
and going into Avenger Secret Wars and
this will be where things start to
really connect going forward because the
heroes are now going to be in constant
contact with each other and learning
about what is happening in the
Multiverse so this film will be a game
changer for the current state of the MCU
right now if you felt like it was
lacking a little bit it's going to
completely change after this film the
tone and the pacing of the MCU is going
to be completely different but again I
also spoke of a different project a
project that is going to start to fill
in some gaps for other films and shows
and that project is the project that is
going to immediately follow up Captain
America Brave New World and that is the
Thunderbolts the Thunderbolts and
Captain America Brave New World are
going to be two huge pivotal points for
the MCU we recently heard from the
director of the Thunderbolts and from
insiders as well give giving us some
info about the movie and how it will
fill in gaps we'll talk about that in
just a bit but first a big thank you to
bird dogs for sponsoring this video If
you struggle with finding good shorts to
wear ones that actually fit and actually
look good the struggle is over bird dogs
make you look good and they are
extremely comfortable bird dogs are
specifically designed to look slimmer on
the thigh and the leg giving you a
sculpted look and the best part is they
are stretch khaki shorts they do the
exact same thing as Lululemon but they
fit way better most shorts out there
don't fit very well they're pretty
restricting they're stiff the cotton
they use is pretty terrible but bird
dog's fixes this issue by inventing
Cloud knit fabric that looks just like
khaki but stretches so you get a waist
Slimmer fit without having to sacrifice
movement they also use anti-stink sweat
weakening fabric that helps keep you
cool and dry all day long I've
personally really struggled with shorts
because I'm not a tall guy and I'm kind
of bulky and I have not been able to
find shorts that aren't too long that
actually allow me to move but now I have
with bird dogs they are awesome and the
best part is if you order a pair you get
a free Yeti style tumbler so go to
birddogs.com Cosmic for a free Yeti
style tumbler with your order that's
style tumbler you won't want to take
your bird dogs off we promise you
so in Captain America Brave New World
and the Thunderbolts are where things
are going to start to turn around and
where you're going to really start to
feel the connectivity of all of the
different projects that have been
happening and today we've heard from
Insider can we get some toast and we've
even heard from the director of the
upcoming Thunderbolts movie Jake
schreier he says that the Thunderbolts
project will not serve as a sequel to
any previous Marvel project yes these
characters have appeared before but it
is a new story being told in a story
with a very different perspective than
people are expecting is what he recently
told collider in which The Insider can
we get some toast responded to that
tweet stating not a sequel no but
Thunderbolts does follow up on Ant-Man
and the WASP Black Widow Falcon and the
Winter Soldier and Hawkeye it'll fill in
the gaps of where everyone's been since
those projects and what they've been up
to and of course if we take a look at
the characters that are a part of the
Thunderbolts that just makes sense we're
going to figure out what these people
and who they're associated with have
been up to over the years and that'll
bring a different connectivity to the
MCU but still making it feel more
connected but that's not all it's going
to do this is actually going to set up
events that are going to take place
beyond phase six of the MCU we've
learned that the Thunderbolts are going
to go to tie up an island to try and get
adamantium for the US government we've
also heard a rumor that the Weapon X
Program could be introduced in the MCU
in the Thunderbolts project and if they
are going for adamantium this makes
sense now of course the mzu could switch
things up a little bit and it could be
Thunderbolt Ross who is in charge of the
Weapon X Program along with Valentina
again story wise in the MCU this makes
sense Ross has been experimenting with
super soldier serum for the longest time
now Valentina is the one who put the
Thunderbolts together it would make
sense that they would want a different
enhanced team one that they have created
literally so regardless of the fact that
the Thunderbolts is going to fill in
some MCU gaps it is also going to be a
big setup for the future as well and I
think everything for the MCU is really
going to start to come together thanks
to these two films that aren't that far
away so if you're one of the fans that
have been waiting for that specific
connective feeling of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you don't have to
wait that much longer but go ahead and
let us know what you think about this in
the comments down below please don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
foreign